Було відчуття ну такого знаєте
люті гніву
тому що Ну як
чому ці ракети летять в бік мого міста
нині військова агресія Росії
парадоксальним чином
прискорила процеси входження нашої
культури у свідомості європейських націй
другий етапом цієї Перемоги
будуть неминучі після цього вступ до
НАТО і до Європейського Союзу
в будь-якому разі перемога
потрібна як повітря і як вода
ми по-іншому взагалі жодного майбутнього
немає маємо
насамперед Дозвольте привітати вас з
присудженням премії імені Генріха Гейне
від міста Дюссельдорф вас нагородили як
українського письменника поета і
перекладача який репрезентує
ідентичність України як культурної нації
в чому ви бачите свою гуманітарну місію
за кордоном як представника української
культури під час війни в Україні
значною мірою це пов'язано із особливою
ситуацію воєнною ситуацією в якій наша
країна тепер відповідно
будь-яка моя моя зустріч тут з читами з
громадськістю так чи інакше вона не
обходиться без цієї теми без спілкування
на цю тему і Ну я дуже радий що Власне
кажучи
на ці начебто сутою літературні зустрічі
приходять люди
яких
[музика]
набагато більше в них зацікавлені і
зокрема вони всі дуже вболівають за
Україну підтримують нас ну це крім того
що безпосередньо українці Які Тут живуть
або тимчасово перебувають Вони теж
приходять на ці зустрічі от я думаю це
важливо
в тому сенсі що це не тільки я
український митці які мають якісь
виступи
якісь проєкти з-за кордону з закордонною
аудиторією працюють
Ну ми всі демонструємо те що
нашу країну не зламали
наша культура не хмм просто там якось
виживає і живе А вона
в такому надзвичайно активному хоч і
доволі турбулентному стані і ось ця
культурна присутність в європейській
свідомості так зокрема тут у німецькій
її було не так багато протягом тривалого
часу
ось нині військова агресія Росії
парадоксальним чином
прискорила процеси е-е входження нашої
культури у свідомість європейських націй
і цим моментом треба користатися Ну я от
один із тих які користаються в мене
склалося Це доволі вдало Тому що
мій найновіший Роман радіо ніч якраз
минулого місяця
побачив світ у німецькому перекладі і
дуже хорошому
одному із провідних видавництв Німеччині
як згуркампії Ну а це означає що
до нього прикута доволі велика увага і
склався такий план
і з 12 міст
тобто справді непогана можливість
не просто зустрічатися з німецькою
публікою і розповідати про свою книжку
але і
розповідати значно більше всього
якими на ваш погляд є настрої в
німецькому суспільстві щодо війни в
Україні
за моїми відчуттями
більшість суспільства нас підтримує і
дедалі краще розуміє
чому
скажімо Ми не можемо іти на якесь там
швидке перемир'я
домовлятися з ворогом цього розуміння
стає дедалі більше але є також частина
суспільства яка
або така традиційно проросійська
особливо для
регіонів колишньої східної Німеччини
характерно так ну або вона
така в
сенсі
такому догматичному Це просто такі
пацифісти так які традиційно сподобалось
тільки одне якомога
скоріше мир тому що війна війна війна -
це погано ну і
є такий ще прошарок
антеамериканський так
Десь глибоко це сидить в ментальності
німецької нації
Ну ось це люди які ще досі вважають що
насправді А це американо російський
конфлікт це Україна Нічого в ньому не
вирішує
і Україну Ці дві начебто
потужні сили Хоча з них лише одна Як ми
знаємо насправді потужна але ось вони
Україну начебто розривають Так е-е
кожна тягне у свій бік і безумовно що
тут
Ані один письменник А ні група
письменників так принципово нічого не
змінить бо люди такого типу вони і не
приходять Власне кажучи на ці зустрічі
Але я думаю що все разом якби і
політичні зусилля
і
передусім успіх
наших збройних сил Ну і потім оця ж таки
культурна дипломатія яка на багатьох на
багатьох рівнях поступово звичайно може
змінювати картину може
діяти позитивно Які відчуття вас були на
початку війни 24 лютого 25 лютого що ви
відчували Було відчуття ну такого знаєте
люті гніву
тому що Ну як
чому ці ракети летять в бік мого міста
Хто тут має хазяйнувати взагалі що вони
що вони взагалі собі вирішили
вдертися в наше життя
це було щось таке не пояснене так ось і
до цього треба було звикати Але я вважаю
що
вони були жахливі так вони були дуже
важкі ці перші дні але вони
уже принесли нам
якусь таку певність що ми це Здолаємо ну
тобто починаючи з першого дня наші
збройні сили їх як то кажуть крушили Ми
весь час отримували
в прямому етері а
з наших телевізійних новин з інтернету
Ми весь час отримували якісь позитивні
новини а там уже збили перший літак а
там уже захопили перших полонених Так а
там відбили атаку А ось уже горить танк
тобто насправді з першого дня з'явилася
е-е з'явилася ця
переможна нота так би мовити
осені на літературному фестивалі в
Норвегії з російськомовним письменником
Михайлом шишкіним скажемо так обурив
частину українського суспільства як ви
взагалі ставитеся до діалогу з
представниками російської культури за
нинішніх умов є
індивідуальні дуже індивідуальні речі
особисті які ну дуже бажано бачити в
певному контексті Тобто це стосується не
тільки цих
так званих росіян хороші вони чи не
хороші але це стосується також
наших європейських друзів
і ми мусимо враховувати Ми хочемо стати
частиною Європи
ми стаємо частиною Європи і ми мусимо
враховувати те що
європейці трохи по-іншому ну суттєво
по-іншому дивляться на цю проблему ніж
ми можливо нам хотілося б щоб вони також
так
всіх росіян ненавиділи і щоб вони
були впевнені що хороших росіян не буває
але так На жаль не є
жодна з цих країн поки що не стала
у прямому розумінні жертвою агресії і
відповідно
Треба враховувати цей момент тобто треба
працювати
в залежності від кожного конкретного
випадку звичайно працювати ще й так щоб
від цього було максимально багато
користі для України
найпростіше Це просто відмовитися І
наприклад сказати тим
організаторам норвезького фестивалю ні я
не буду А Ми не спілкуємося з росіянами
Ну ось але є і інша можливість можна
прийти і говорити про те про що вважаєш
за потрібне говорити Тим більше
що
співучасник
моєї розмови
Пушкін
насправді прийшов і з
наративом який для України дуже корисний
і потрібний
от тобто тут немає єдиного принципу Ось
у чому розходження
моєї з тими людьми які як кажуть
обурилися тому що люди які обурилися
встановили
певний догматичний принцип
Ми навіть не дивимося хто там нас нічого
не цікавить Ми
вирішили так Ну хтось вирішив хтось не
вирішив Так я жодного такого суспільного
договору не підписував Особисто я
вважаю
що в мене є моральне право вирішувати
самому де це буде потрібно А де це не
буде потрібно і ну і ще раз Хочу
повторити насправді
а тут ідеться не про якийсь
жест підтримки у бік хороших руських
я в них не вірю так само як і більшість
українців
але тут ідеться про жести діалогу в бік
європейських наших партнерів
вони ці речі організовують їм це
потрібно значить хай вони почують тоді
інакше вони не почують
так мені здається
головний герой вашого нового роману
радіо ніч Йосип роцький це по суті такі
сучасні Орфей провідник між суспільством
та мистецтвом згадуючи його ім'я ви
визначаєте його як претензійний гібрид
бродського і рота чому ви обрали саме
такі алюзії
[музика]
я спершу знайшов тобто мені знайшлося
мені
звідкись там упало це ім'я і прізвище
Йосип Руцький тоді я подумав А Ну
звичайно всі почують в ньому
Йосиф оборотського і для рівноваги
я згадав про Йозеф рота ну вийшло так
трошки смішно а насправді
Йозеф рот і
той самий Йосиф Бродський
вони доволі далекі так як письменники
але їх об'єднує одна дуже така показова
штука
обидва вони пережили
падіння розпад фактично розпад імперій
в яких жили Я як дуже глибокого
особистого трагедію
Йозеф рот
пережив так трагічно розпад
австро-угорської імперії і свій
найкращий Роман написав Так би мовити як
таку розширену епітафію на гробниці цієї
імперії
а Йосиф Бродський хоч який він не був
антирадянщик але
йому було страшенно прикро і боляче
що ця совєцька Імперія розпалася і він
не міг ніяких з цим заспокоїтися і
нарешті з нього
виліз цей жахливий вірш
проти України і всього українського для
мого героя якраз
розпад імперії в який він теж певний час
пожив це якраз велике свято
тому я казав би про те що можливо тут
швидше така
фонетична так
Забава трошки з цими іменами і
прізвищами
але за суттю своєю
це якийсь цілком
інший так
інший тип митця Скажіть будь ласка зараз
ми бачимо як в Україні перейменують
вулиці які носять імена російських
письменників ми бачимо демонтаж
пам'ятників чи має залишитися щось з
російською культурою в українському
просторі Чи треба від неї взагалі
відмовитися Я знову ж таки ви вважаю що
тут є якісь моменти де треба враховувати
певні індивідуальні речі от скажімо Я не
мав би нічого проти аби що був у наших
містах там де вони були щоб залишалися
вулиці Герцена
тому що герцен був великим борцем проти
російського самодержавства і
прихильником
ліберальних цінностей
настільки наскільки можна було ним бути
в його час у 19 столітті але я також не
буду знаєте з розпачем
ставитись до того що ці вулиці
перейменують
я не буду захищати збереження цієї назви
інша річ що коли перейменовують доволі
часто
виникають
якась монотонія в Нових назвах ось не
обов'язково оці нові назви
є якимись такими дуже вдалими
пригадую коли в нашому місті почалася
хвиля перейменувань у нас виявилося десь
із десяток або і більше нових вулиць всі
одного типу так героїв Маріуполя героїв
Харкова героїв Бучі
героїв ще там інших міст і це ж Ну
насправді свідчить ну про якусь таку
монотонію мислення так про відсутність
уяви
зрозуміло що ми вшановуємо ми вшановуємо
всіх своїх співвітчизників
але все воно таке безособове Знаєте таке
назва
масова от героїв Маріуполя а прізвище
мені назвіть тому я просто думаю що це
не такий собі
мав би бути гарячковий процес
але із іншого боку Я дуже добре розумію
ту емоцію яка
за цим стоїть
президент України Володимир Зеленський
Після оголошення в Росії часткової
мобілізації звернувся до росіян і
застеріг їх від участі у війні в Україні
Як ви вважаєте чи потрібно взагалі
звертатися до росіян сьогодні чи є в
цьому сенс Мені здається що з тактичних
міркувань Це добре Це правильно тому що
ну вноситься певне сум'яття Так це
частина інформаційної війни насправді
він бере особисту участь він в
інформаційній війні і
апелює до населення країни ворога
Ну не буде Цього діалогу Просто
немає ще не не досягнуто
Росії
того рівня
це суспільство дуже занепали воно
деградоване і і воно продовжує
деградувати так Тобто це не буде почуто
насправді за великим рахунком це цього
не чують і знову ж таки соціологія
підтверджує що там
попри всі не популярні якісь оці
мобілізаційні заходи і так далі Вони
залишаються такими якими були Тобто їх
це не виправляє на вулиці з протестами
вони не виходять не те що з маслом вони
вже й з якимось не масовими поодинокими
протестами не виходять От так що я
особливо сенсу цього не бачу це не
означає що так буде завжди
це треба собі добре затягнути
Ми живемо в змінному світі
Можливо
навіть неможливо Мені здається так
неминуче буде розвиток подій А сам сюжет
цієї війни
призведе до того що
в Росії почне формуватися нарешті якась
частина суспільства
здатна почути Ну якщо здатна почути то
це вже якийсь там перший крок до діалогу
це ще не означає що діалог вже
розпочався але вже ніби буде якесь там
поле для нього
Як ви вважаєте за яких умов може
закінчитися війна в Україні
Я думаю
однозначно тут
неспроможність військова нашого ворога
вичерпаність його передусім збройного
ресурсу тому що людського в нього ще
багато але такого дедалі менш якісно
і
для мене
однозначним знаком Перемоги
буде не лише повернення України до
кордонів визнаних міжнародним правом
себто до кордонів з яких почалася наша
незалежна держава але і
так би мовити другим етапом цієї
Перемоги
будуть неминучі після цього вступ до на
цьому відео Європейського Союзу і вони
зафіксують обидві ці структури але
передусім НАТО звичайно але Європейський
союз у цьому сенсі теж дуже важливий
зафіксується
оте що
ми стали частиною західного світу
більше
ніколи з жодних обставин російський
агресор
хоч як там буде ще змінюватися їхня
внутрішньополітичне життя уже не полізе
і
це буде вже так назавжди
якою на ваш погляд вийде Україна після
перемоги у цій війні
Ну звичайно
буде складно оцінити однозначно як
завжди в будь-якому разі
перемога
потрібна як повітря і як вода і ми
по-іншому взагалі жодного майбутнього
немає маємо
мені навіть не хочеться і Уявляти собі
якийсь інший варіант а це означає
великий
психологічний
якби
прорив так в суспільній
свідомості українців
це означає велику віру в себе це означає
соціальний оптимізм його і на сьогодні
доволі багато це дивовижні
дивовижну високі відсотки які показують
що
українці з оптимізмом дивляться у
майбутнє якщо це цей стан закріплений ще
й таким явищем як перемога то це
звичайно дуже великий плюс для відбудови
країни для її тотального такого
оновлення
Насправді Я дуже вірю в те що
дуже потужні інвестиції врятують і е-е
це все
позитив те що
буде багато болю багато смутку
багато
людей яким просто Ну треба буде їх треба
буде витягувати з депресії там потрібні
будуть дуже серйозні зусилля також
усього суспільства що в цих людей
незліченно їх їх дуже багато тих і які
все втратили або щось дуже важливе
втратили повертати їх до життя так
і я думаю що там ще багато багато-багато
небезпек на нашому шляху тобто
різних ліній
які розділяють людей так скажімо
на тих хто сидів за кордоном І хто
воював на передовій
хто не воював на передовій взагалі не
воював і хто був в окупації і так далі І
так далі тобто за бажання можна
нарахувати безліч якихось конфліктів і я
вважаю що
їх краще собі уявляти уже
їхній так би мовити негативний потенціал
для того щоб
їх уникати
дякую дякую вам